how about I fire you perfect I've been
waiting to get fired from uh from some
of my responsibilities
excellent excellent so here it goes the
first thing I'm gonna do is let you know
hey this is gonna be a difficult
conversation you're likely gonna fear
feel some combination of fear anger
sadness I want to let you know that so
you can prepare for that
are you ready
yes
[Music]
all right guys I've got Matt here with
the Matt I thought a great place for us
to start is this idea of fear and anger
and I know that you usually will say
fear and anger give bad advice but I
actually think it's an interesting point
of fear and anger doesn't just give bad
advice it does all of the thinking for
someone when they are in that fearful
moment or they are filled with anger can
you talk through a little bit in terms
of how people can identify that they
actually have a moment of fear or anger
in the moment
yeah that's a really good question it's
actually really tough for someone to
like self-identify when they're in fear
or anger
um because what happens is a different
part of the brain takes over so when
we're feeling joyful or peaceful or
excited our prefrontal cortex is where
the majority of our thought is coming
from and that's creative thought and
um and so but when we feel fear and
anger suddenly our thinking goes back
into our amygdala and we don't notice it
it's just thoughts appear to us but
those thoughts are generated from our
basal stem and they are it's called our
custom Bill referred to as our reptile
brain because it has a very simplistic
thinking the thinking is either it's
fight or flight either I tell this
threat or I run away from it but again
because it is just our thoughts we don't
notice the difference between these
thoughts and those thoughts and we can't
tell it basically envelops us like a
shield as if we were a goldfish in a pot
of water the Goldfish doesn't know it's
in water because it's just that's
everything and so we don't know that
these we're in fear because it's just
everything for us and so really the only
the easy way to identify word fear anger
is to have people around us that we have
empowered and said please let me know
and then they give a signal and they say
I think you're perceived to be in fear
or they stick up their finger or
something and that is the only easy way
that I know of to identify self-identify
when I'm in fear anger the other way to
self-identify
it requires a lot of meditation so that
you can actually start to really notice
the physical Sensations in your body and
the emotions that come from those
Sensations so you can actually notice
when they occur when you're not
meditating but that requires a lot of
meditation a daily practice of maybe an
hour a day and I don't recommend it once
somebody identifies whether themselves
or an external Source you are in fear
you are filled with anger in this moment
the next thing that they will jump to is
how do I switch back to a point of
Happiness a point of control of my
emotions and point of calmness some
people will argue and there's plenty of
literature that would support that it is
a physiological thing you can actually
do things to your body some people will
say no it is merely uh something that
can be done via the way you think you
don't actually make any changes to your
body
um some people will say it could be food
some people will say that you need to
just get away from the computer there's
all these different things that people
will say this is the path to gaining
control back is it unique to everyone or
are there one or two specific things
that you say no matter who you are if
you're in that moment of fear or anger
you can do this and it will return you
back to some level of normalcy
every single thing you just said works
so these are there are many many paths
to get out of fear and anger
changing your physical environment
literally getting up and walking into
another room
that's often enough
doing physical exercise to get the blood
flowing that's often enough
thinking what's good about this
situation that's often enough
so there are many ways to get out of
fear and anger and I recommend people
just experiment with all of them
you have this quote in uh in your book
that says learning how to run a company
while running a company is extremely
hard and I found that fascinating
because most Founders try to learn how
to run a business when they're running
their first business at the same time I
think that there would be an argument
you can't simply read about running a
business you have to run one to actually
learn how do you balance those two
things learning on the job is hard but
also learning from a book or from a
lecture or from watching a video is also
hard if not impossible and so where is
that balance
yeah it's again it's a tough one and uh
you have to have the experience to know
what the problems actually are and then
you have to have the time to read and
study the solutions to those problems
which you often don't have when you're
actually running the business I mean
that's why I wrote The Great CEO within
the way I did which is just basically
it's a bunch of bullet points it's a
bunch of one-page summaries of other 350
page books that have great Solutions but
really those Solutions can be described
in one or two pages you don't need the
348 other Pages
um so yeah I think summaries of books
are fantastic while you are actually
actively being a CEO when I was reading
the book one of the questions I kept
saying to myself is someone who runs a
whole bunch of different organizations
some of them in the investment World
some of them as operating businesses is
I want to hand this to as many of our
leaders as possible but is there any
point in the organization we're actually
having them read the book gives them so
much information that is not applicable
to their day-to-day like entry level
position or your customer service rep or
maybe your engineers is it leadership
only or do you think actually there's
value in the book to everyone in the
organization because it helps them think
like a CEO
it's a great question I don't
I don't really think In fairness
I don't know what people's reaction to
the book is
um I wrote the book five years ago
um I am constantly updating the comment
on my own gold doc which is out there
for free
um I have heard people say that it's
valuable for anyone in the organization
because then again they understand how
the CEO is thinking and they can better
operate the way the CEO would hope that
they would operate
um but I think you're probably better
off the better person to answer because
you've actually read the book as a user
would whereas I've never sat down and
read the book as a user since I wrote it
I like I made two movies I
don't watch the movies I mean I've seen
them a thousand times in the edit room
but I've never sat down and watched the
movie as a new viewer so I don't know
what the new reader of the book what
their experience actually is you know
that better than I did explain why you
don't do that with the with the movies
it's very common I I have these
conversations I don't go back and listen
to the podcast episodes right there's
many other people who have created
things in the world they put it out into
the world and they'll say I actually
didn't read the book from cover to cover
I didn't watch the movie I didn't listen
to the podcast why do you think people
do that
um it's listening to your own voice or
listening to my own voice it's like to
me it's it's not interesting your voice
is more interesting to me than mine is
I've already had these thoughts I've
already documented them going back and
experiencing them again
doesn't add new thoughts or information
to my life I'm curious I'd like to know
more about what you have to say what
others have to say
is
also I I reviewed the content so many
times in the writing and the thinking
that I'm kind of like
kind of over it
there are a number of studies that show
uh people hate their voice that is like
not just the thing you think it is
definitely a thing that has been proven
and that when they hear back their voice
they just kind of cringe and say wow I
really sound like that
true exactly
um let's talk about meetings because I
know you all have a very specific way
that you think meetings should be run
um I think this is probably one of the
biggest areas where if a founder or
leadership team can learn how to quickly
do this uh it can have a profound impact
on the organization literally starting
you know this afternoon right it's
something that once you learn how to do
it and you get the team up to speed on
it uh it begins to uh reap the benefits
as an organization almost immediately
one of the things that I have personally
experienced and I'd love for you to kind
of help me think through it is in these
meetings a lot of times there are folks
who have a lot of experience they've
been in a lot of meetings they know what
makes a good meeting what doesn't make a
good meeting but there are people who do
not as well and so what you're almost
dealing with is like professional
meeting attendees and amateur meeting
attendees how do you think about just
getting everyone on the same kind of
Level Playing Field in terms of
knowledge and expectations as a starting
point before you even have the meeting
yeah well first of all I recommend
writing up a document of saying here's
what I think a good meeting should look
like share it with everyone who's going
to be in the meeting and say do you
agree
is this how we should do this or do you
have other suggestions and better ways
and basically come to an agreement of
how the meeting should be run before you
even start it and I think that a few key
components are you say there are a lot
of people out there who know what good
meetings look like I'm not sure there
are
um I haven't experienced many good
meetings out there I would say 95
percent of meetings suck actually and
that's what most people have experience
with most meetings are a lot of talking
and that is just super inefficient
there is now starting to be a culture
that is spreading of written preparation
because Amazon is so famously
uses that and that now that knowledge of
spreading because Amazon is so
successful that people are starting to
copy the Amazon
behaviors
um but that's only recent that that's
happening and so I would say that
um I mean I'll just throw out our
meeting Doc is free it's available I
would if you don't have a doc start with
that as a starting point and there are a
few key principles one is is that if a
meeting doesn't have a meeting owner
it's guaranteed going to be a
crappy meeting in the end because no
one's taking responsibility for how good
the meeting is
and if you have a meeting owner then at
the end of the meeting that meeting
owner should ask for feedback on how was
this meeting
absolute scale one to five three being
meeting expectation five being it
couldn't be any better one being it
couldn't be any worse and then what'd
you like about it and what would get it
to the next level
and if you ask people to write their
feedback
and write it all at the same time that
process only needs to take two minutes
so it's not like you're sucking up a
huge amount of meeting time to do that
and if you do those two things you will
eventually create great meetings but in
between if you want to start off with
better I think that
almost all meeting content can be
created asynchronously and it's much
more effective if it is because know
that when people get together that is
very expensive time so you want to use
it for the stuff that can't be done
asynchronously and there's only two
things that I know of that can't be done
asynchronously one
give and receive feedback why because
when I give feedback to someone there's
a chance that they get offended they get
triggered they get angry they get
fearful they get sad and if that happens
I want to say hey wait a second I meant
that with love I didn't mean to hurt you
I want you to succeed and I believe this
is what will help you succeed
so I can catch that and bring them back
out of a state of fear anger or sadness
but if I give that feedback
asynchronously and they read it or
listen to it or watch it in a video and
I don't see their reaction and they get
triggered
I can't stop it and because of
confirmation bias confirmation bias is
when we have a thought or a belief we
then start to see evidence that confirms
that belief
and so because of confirmation bias if
someone feels anger when I give feedback
and I don't stop it within about 48
Hours they've collected enough evidence
that I'm the devil
that our relationship is then
permanently destroyed or near
permanently it will require a lot of
effort to repair so that's why it's very
dangerous to give feedback
asynchronously the second thing that
needs to happen secrecy is to make
people feel heard around a decision
around whatever comments and thoughts
they had to make someone truly feel
heard I've got to hear them not only
read it but hear them say it and even
better repeat back to them what I think
they said until they say yes that's it
and so before I make a decision I always
want to make at least one or two key
participants in the meeting feel heard
and generally read everyone's and show
everyone that I've read all their
comments
and that needs to happen synchronously
so a few minutes around each decision a
few minutes of
receiving feedback or giving feedback
and that's it so a meeting can needs
only take 15 minutes
to make key decisions and receive and
give and receive feedback
but the preparation
needs to be there in writing for that
meeting to only take 15 minutes because
what needs to happen is all the topics
need to be pre-written
and ideally
need to be pre-read and pre-commented
now that's tough to organize everyone to
pre-write 24 hours before the meeting
and then everyone pre-read and
pre-comment that's pretty tough that
requires a lot of discipline I don't
know many companies that do that brex
does Rex is one example that at their
leadership team that's how they they run
their meetings but most companies simply
require
pre-writes and then everyone reads
synchronously at the beginning of the
meeting and writes in their comments
that's how Amazon does it and that's
much easier to achieve
when people are sitting there reading
simultaneously and then leaving comments
at the start of the meeting how much of
the discipline is that people actually
put the comments in writing versus just
pop your head up and say Hey Joe hey
Sarah this is my thoughts on what you
wrote here right the the ability to
speak seems faster but actually may
cause inefficiency uh for the entire
team or those not in the meeting so is
that the main discipline Point inside of
the meeting is the commenting absolutely
the main discipline that before any
verbal discussion begins there's one
round of co-writing from everybody
because it absolutely is faster for one
person to talk rather than to write but
for five people
you can do a little test have each
person say their thing or have everyone
co-write for two minutes at the same
time there's no question co-writing is
way faster to get all the thoughts from
the entire group and what happens when
you don't do co-writing is that the only
people that speak are the people that
are bold there are always going to be
two or three people that never speak and
the first time someone does co-writing
the manager in my experience the CEO was
always shocked like oh my God those two
three people I thought they had nothing
interesting to say turns out they have
the best thoughts of anybody they're
just shy
so you're you're actually losing
tremendously valuable information by
having by allowing people to respond
verbally rather than writing because the
talkative people will just talk and the
non-toxic people will just stay quiet
and you'll lose their you lose their
thoughts there's a number of situations
that Founders have gone through over the
last couple of years that they've
brought up to me in private uh in
conversation whether it's at a dinner
and a social event or just a one-on-one
meeting and I'd love to throw a couple
of those ideas out at you some of them
are actual problems some of them are are
things that are considering and then
maybe we could just Riff on each one of
these as a way for people to understand
some of the thought process you guys
have and some of the coaching that you
do with some of the best CEOs in the
world the first is over the 2020 to 2023
time period there was a number of
pressure points within these
organizations where employees would come
to leadership teams and say hey I think
that we should be doing more on X
activity a lot of times that was
something that had uh social issues it
had to do with donating uh money off of
the balance sheet it had to do with
participating in the local community or
behind some sort of movement and I think
leadership teams would sit there and say
well we're here to do why which is
driver profit solve our customers
problems and create a company but also I
want to make sure that my employees feel
heard that they feel like we're doing
the right thing and that this is a place
that they want to work at and so many
times what I saw Founders doing was they
kind of just threw their hands up like I
don't know what the answer is and so
they would talk to each other but they
were talking to other people who were
throwing their hands up saying I don't
know what the answer is and so I'm sure
you dealt with this a couple of times in
your coaching but just how should
Founders think about those situations
are there things they could do in
advance to help prevent it uh getting to
that point or the things they could do
to address it immediately so that it
doesn't become a problem and instead
maybe they look at it as an opportunity
for a positive outcome
yeah I think the key here is
for each founder there's no question
that founder-led product companies have
a better track record than professional
you know Hired Gun LED product companies
because the founder has a knowledge of
the customer that is so deep because
they you know did it from day one they
talked to so many customers understood
the problem and created the original
solution
um and I know you're wondering what does
this have to do with you know these
culture things that I just talked about
and here's what it has to do with
it's key that the founder really enjoy
the company that they've built so they
they stay there
and I've had Founders that say to me
Matt I no longer enjoy this company
I show up to work whether
in person or remote and it's not fun
anymore
and to those Founders I've said well
what would [__] what would make it fun
what would be a company that you'd enjoy
and they say if it did this this and
this I go great have it do those three
things and they say but if that happens
you know maybe they'll be a front page
article about me in the New York Times
fashioning and I say okay so there'll be
a front page article about you in the
New York Times and then what
because if you don't do that
You're Gonna Leave This company
is the outcome going to be worse than
that I go no
so then they post a letter and say hey
you know these issues that people talk
about we're not going to deal with them
in this company we're going to deal with
the mission of this company if you want
to deal with those things you deal with
them on your own time privately if you
want to be at a company
that is a political platform please join
another company that's not this company
that's one example of what you could do
or there are other Founders that are
very excited about these political
issues and want their company to be a
platform to them I say great make your
company a platform the only time that I
push Founders is when they say they want
an apolitical company
but they're too afraid to make that
announcement and declare that and those
that's where fear is is giving bad
advice and that's where I push founders
in these situations it seems like
employees over the last couple of years
have been emboldened they'd get kind of
a bigger voice internally is the
expectation and what Founders kind of
have to get comfortable with that when
you come out and say this is going to be
an a political organization you just
have to be comfortable with some of the
employees leaving if they don't want
that environment and like that's just
part of uh this exercise
absolutely yes I mean that that's the
whole point of values values is
behaviors and the whole point of saying
these are the behaviors that we'll have
is that they're a way of identifying who
should join your company and who should
not and of the people who are already at
your company who should stay and who
shouldn't because the behaviors should
be very distinctive and we're seeing
this now a lot of CEOs are saying you
know what we've been remote for a while
but I don't want to be remote I want to
go back into the office
and they say is that okay for me to say
I said of course it's okay for you to
say just be ready though they're going
to be a bunch of people that don't want
to go back and they shouldn't be there
they're going to be three categories of
people they're going to be people who
are really excited to be back in the
office great they're gonna be the people
who aren't excited to be back in the
office and they'll just leave on their
own because they're smart enough to
realize that they should do what matches
their own values and they should find a
company that still is remote the
dangerous part is they're gonna be a
bunch of people who aren't going to be
happy but will be too afraid to leave
and those are the people that you as
founder need to help them I
self-identify and help them find a great
job in a remote company because your
company no longer is so if you create an
a political organization yes great
expect that there will be people who
will say okay I don't want to be part of
this I want to go join a company that is
political
those people are fine that's not
dangerous the dangerous ones are the
ones who stay and are frustrated those
are the ones that you need to identify
and say hey this place is not for you
let's go find you a place that is for
you
another situation that Founders seem to
be running into over and over and over
again is they know that there's somebody
who's on their team that is not meeting
the standard or meeting the bar uh but
they don't like conflict and so they try
to avoid that conflict that then
permeates down and the leadership team
does the same thing many times then when
the leadership team does that the middle
management does that and you kind of go
all the way through the organization and
so naturally some of the people who
should be let go uh they kind of stick
around if we go back to that moment
where it is one on one the manager and
the managed uh there has to be a
conversation what is the conversation
that people can have so that it is a
thoughtful kind but very obvious and
strict we are letting you go and here is
what is going to happen from here
yeah it's a difficult conversation most
people don't like having difficult
conversations
um some people mind it more than others
I've had Founders who have gone into
full
panic attacks
knowing that they
we together have decided that they need
to let this person go and when they
actually go to do it they go into a
panic attack beforehand and then they
they don't and I
so until a manager or CEO has let go of
one person
I don't trust that they know how I don't
trust that they're able to
and the way that I the script that I
give managers to have this difficult
conversation is really what their what
they're fearful of is the impact that
it's going to have on the person they're
letting go
and we talked before about the
prefrontal cortex and the amygdala
the amygdala is where pure and anger
occurred the amygdala usually gets
triggered because it's surprised
something happens suddenly
but if you if you let a person know hey
something's about to come
and they can prepare themselves then
they often don't get triggered they go
and so what I do is I say to someone
um is now a good time to talk and I say
yeah agree
um
I want to let you know in fact let's do
this for real
um how about I fire you perfect I've
been waiting to get fired from uh from
some of my responsibilities
excellent excellent so here it goes the
first thing I'm gonna do is let you know
hey this is going to be a difficult
conversation you're likely going to fear
feel
some combination of fear anger sadness I
want to let you know that so you can
prepare for that
are you ready
yes
I'm letting you go today
is your last day at work here
let me explain to you why
then I do explain your we need only
outperformers here your performance has
been good but not great and I want to
help you find a place where your
performance will be great or they really
need you
so I realize this is a traumatic
experience to lose your primary income
and I don't want it to be traumatic so
I'm going to do two things one I'm going
to give you Severance of three months so
that you have enough time to not only
find but also start getting paid in your
next role and two I want to be your
agent I want to actively help you
identify what would be a phenomenal role
for you either start your own company or
role in another company that you'd
actually
love and you do fantastic at and then I
want to actively help you go find that
job like me be your agent I will reach
out to my network and encourage people
to hire you I won't just be passive and
say hey I'll give you a reference no
I'll be active those are the two things
that I'd like to give to you and third
actually I think about it is this is a
traumatic experience you likely will be
feeling fear anger it'll be hard to
process and I don't want you to process
it alone so I'd like you to be able to
have a therapist that you can talk to
weekly during these three months and I
would like to pay for that therapist
it'll be probably
200 a session so 800 a month and I would
like to pay for those three months for
you you find a therapist that you're
comfortable with but I would like to pay
for that
so everything there makes sense and was
done expertly uh you you are an absolute
uh high quality fire of a manager
um there's one thing that I think a lot
of people question
you becoming the agent you going out
actively and trying to help them find
their next role if this was an
underperformer at your business how do
you balance that with recommending to
friends former colleagues other people
in your network an individual that maybe
you think could be successful somewhere
else but maybe you think couldn't be
yeah absolutely it's a great point and
this is the pushback that people have
and a lot of times they're angry like
this person screwed me they you know
they had were on a key project they told
me they would succeed and get it done
they didn't get it done and that screwed
me with a customer and we lost customers
over it I'm so angry at this person I
want to punish them I want to hurt them
that's just anger talking
the fact is is that that person I am
responsible for hiring a person who
wasn't right for the role I am
responsible for ineffectively onboarding
that person and not giving them enough
contacts to context to succeed I am
responsible for not managing them well
and giving them feedback ongoing saying
hey this needs to improve here's what
you need to do to make it improve I fail
to do all those three things so I need
to take responsibility for that and also
I need to recognize that this person
wasn't right for this role in my company
but there is something that this person
is passionate about and if they're
passionate about it they're likely going
to be great at it and I just need to ask
them and interview them what are you
passionate about you clearly weren't
passionate about this role but what are
you passionate about and let's go see if
there's an income producing
business or job around that passion and
if there is then I'm very happy to
recommend that for you but am I going to
recommend you for the exact same role
that you had in my company and another
company no way yeah the other uh piece
of maybe Insider or advice that you give
in the book and I know in your coaching
is this idea of a CEO for a day where
you you or others would go into a
company and basically run the business
for a day and it's a way for you to
teach a CEO how to operate how to run
business or how to run meetings how to
interface with their leadership team or
other employees things like that and
what I took away from that is this idea
of kind of left seat right seat right so
as you are coming in to do that for a
day the founder is basically getting a
front row seat to saying this is the
behavior these are the actions these are
the conversations that happen when
somebody's effectively running the
organization and that's very very
helpful for them in the firing example
it would be weird I think for me to fire
someone and have like a trainee sitting
next to me as I did it but maybe not is
that appropriate is it inappropriate is
there a way for people who need to learn
how to let people go uh get it by
watching someone else do it without it
being inhumane to the person who's being
fired
absolutely I've done it dozens of times
okay and and oftentimes
um and I've never had anyone say man
what the hell is going on why is this
person here because they know this
person is shadowing me because I've sort
of announced hey this person will be
shattering me this week this month this
year
um or I'm showing a manager how to do it
and that manager is the manager of this
person but that manager has never let
anyone go before so I'm letting the
person go I come in as CEO and so it
feels very natural again I've never had
any pushback yeah that that is um uh
fascinating let's switch gears uh from
kind of internal and maybe now to uh
external type communication uh obviously
there is uh an economic crisis or chaos
uncertainty that's unfolding right now
and I think a lot of Founders are kind
of stepping up and they're saying okay I
can't be the peacetime CEO I need to be
more of the wartime CEO and people will
debate isn't it always wartime but let's
just use that analogy for the moment
in those moments there is a change in
communication that I see Founders taking
whether it is on podcast in interviews
with the press in the way that they
communicate on Twitter or other social
media what are maybe some things that
you've seen Founders do in these moments
of uncertainty and Chaos that they
should not do so what are like the
things to avoid in these moments
hmm
well I've seen a lot of people things
that people are doing that they should
be doing okay so let's start with those
um
they're they're sort of investors have
two modes and investors are putting
their foot either very hard on the gas
pedal or very hard on the break
and I'm gonna go back you said your
question about Founders Matt why are you
talking about Investors and I'll tell
you why because investors have a huge
influence on Founder Behavior correct so
what happens is when times are good and
the stock market values are going up and
um investors tell their Founders grow as
quickly as you can because whoever
becomes number one in this market
category is going to get a 10x result
versus number two so spend whatever
knowing you need to spend buy or whoever
you need to hire
do pay for whatever ads you need to pay
for to gain that number one market share
they've actually encourage the founder
to spend more to hire more then all of a
sudden the stock market goes down value
start going down investors get really
scared investors go oh no if this
company requires another round of
investment then my investment is going
to effectively get washed out by the way
Founders will often get re-upped by the
new investors so a Down Round for
Founders is an employee current
employees is not such a big deal but a
Down Round for invest existing investors
is a huge deal so that you don't want
this down round to occur and so they put
a lot of pressure on the founder slash
cost fire people let go of the team
again because they're trying to preserve
their own Equity so it doesn't get
diluted
and both of these answers are extreme
but Founders especially younger Founders
newer Founders don't know so they follow
both of these and the answer is you
shouldn't hire so much because the more
you hire
the more context gets lost and you're
now giving responsibility to people who
don't understand the customer fully they
don't understand how the company
operates and it makes it harder to
operate the company the more people
there are in a group the harder it is to
get anything done so there are plenty of
examples I have of
30 40 50 even 80 of a department or a
company leaving and not the worst people
sometimes the best people
and that department then performs better
just because they're fewer people around
so hiring people
is a negative
and you certainly don't want to hire a
lot of people fast
but then on the other hand
cutting costs dramatically
actually is quite positive but I mean if
you see the Elon Musk example everyone
predicted that you know uh Twitter is
going to shut down and he you know let
go of 80 of the people it's gonna like
the website was gonna stop working well
of course that didn't happen works just
fine and so when
companies get reduced headcount-wise
someone will take over someone will get
done the actions that need to get done
because when you were 10 people those
actions occurred when there were 20
people those actions occurred when
you're 50 people when you're a thousand
people and you're 10 000 people you can
go back to almost any number and they
can maintain your product
um so the good things that I see
happening when we need to go into a cut
cost mode is that Founders are being
didactic Founders are saying this I I am
now the decision maker and you marketing
here is the budget you get period for
this coming year it's no longer you come
to me and tell me what budget you need
and argue for it
and so they're simply being given an
envelope they're simply being given a
they're being given the budget they're
not lobbying for the budget and that is
very good behavior because inevitably if
each department is lobbying for their
budget the only thing that happens they
Lobby for more and more and more money
no one's thinking about the bottom line
no one's thinking about profitability
there's only one person maybe two who
are thinking about profitability and
that is the CEO and maybe the CFO so the
CEO becoming didactic about here's the
money you get do whatever you can with
that money that's actually the most
effective solution
let's see what the negative behaviors
are that I'm seeing I'm really not
seeing many now maybe I'm coaching
really good CEOs and I'm recommending to
them behaviors and they're doing those
behaviors so I'm not seeing the negative
ones
um I guess the negative one is really
when the times are good and investors
are pushing fast growth that Founders
actually go and hire at these insane
rates that is very bad behavior
one of the things that I took away from
your book that I just loved was the idea
of the energy audit and it fits nicely
with this framework that I've always had
which is if you were to take a human
being forget any industry job uh or
geography and you simply said to them uh
here here are the best things to do for
your health uh it would be things like
sleep eight hours don't eat processed
food get outside around the Sun uh
exercise right very simple kind of
Timeless Health advice
startup Founders basically live a life
that does everything the exact opposite
they usually don't sleep a lot they
usually eat pretty bad they usually
don't exercise that much and they almost
never go outside because they're sitting
at their computer uh regardless of where
it is
is there any way that you found with a
number of uh your coaching clients to
get them to model the better Behavior
but still feel like they're being
productive and spending the time
necessary to build a startup once
there's so much work to do
yeah you're not gonna like my answer
it's okay this is an area that if the
Founder's feeling good
we leave it as is
if it ain't broke we don't fix it I have
lived both of those lives
and I've enjoyed both of them
uh and I felt good during both of them
and my body and brain felt good during
both of them there's a time when I slept
three hours a night for six months
that was fine it performed just fine I
got a little tired of the afternoon
that's it and so I don't think
that again if someone is feeling
depressed if someone is feeling like
they're not functioning well and they
want to improve it great we go to all
the techniques you just mentioned and
they'll work
but if someone is
working 18 hours a day
hardly sleeping not exercising and
feeling good
and we say fine keep going
yeah that's pretty incredible
um another area that seems most Founders
are trying to figure out is uh
communicating when you have remote
employees and you have in uh office
employees
um and for me personally uh it's very
unique because you want to have the
camaraderie the human face-to-face
interaction uh inside of me digs be able
to walk over uh to people's desks and
kind of do the impromptu stuff obviously
much harder to do with the remote
employees and then you start to deal
with uh people who are remote feel like
the people in the office have an
advantage not necessarily in terms of
like career progression but just they're
able to get access to more information
they they themselves can walk over to a
desk or or be able to uh you know kind
of collaborate in a more impromptu way
how can the people in the office make
the people outside of the office feel
like they are just as involved I know
that you talk a lot about what they can
do in a meeting but are there other
things they can do outside of us
specific meeting to make sure that
there's more of that sense of belonging
or camaraderie
there are things that you can do sure
but they're not going to be 100
effective and you talk about it's not
career progression but actually is
career progression because if someone
has more information and they therefore
can perform tasks more to the liking of
the manager than the manager is going to
say oh I like what you're doing I'm
gonna you know give you more and more
responsibility and so there absolutely
is an advantage to being in person and
developing those relationships with the
manager so
um hybrid you're describing a hybrid
organization you know I got this from
since the brandage
um at gitlab and he famously you know
says that hybrid organizations are very
dangerous either you have it all in
person or you have it all remote but
when you have a combination
no matter how disciplined and
well-meaning the in-person team is to
try to include the remote people and how
would they do that every single time
there was a an informal conversation
they would jump on a zoom call and pull
in the remote people I mean give me a
break that's impossible so the answer is
I think
as an organization pick one or the other
be an all-in person or be an all remote
but don't be mixed
and know that if you choose one or the
other you'll lose a certain percentage
of your team and yes you'll take a hit
and thirty percent of your team will
leave and they'll go join a pure
of the other version if you create a in
person that and they don't want to be in
person they'll go join an all remote
company
but you will then attract people who
really want to be in an all-in-person
company and those people will join you
and they will do very well
and within 12 months you'll have a much
better organization that's performing
the way you want it to perform and the
right people will be there so yes it's a
short-term investment
there will be turnover but it's worth it
within 12 months
that makes sense
um let's talk about the coaching
profession I've actually seen a number
of Founders now start to become coaches
themselves you've had a fantastic career
or definitely seen in Silicon Valley and
other Industries is one of the best
coaches out there what is that like from
your side of the table we've talked a
lot about how Founders can improve and
how Founders can take some of this
information and implement it but what
about from the coach's perspective is
there anything that really stands out
over the last couple of years that has
either changed or surprised you
well first of all I think it's a great
job I freaking love it in fact for a
decade I didn't take any money for doing
it because I was having so much fun I
want to make sure that I only coach
people that I love and only did things
that I love so if I didn't take money or
Equity or make investment then there'd
be no logical reason for me to spend
time with someone or spend time doing
something that I didn't absolutely love
because
I was doing it for free and so that was
a great filter for me because in my mind
if there's money I will get distracted
by the money and so I I eliminated that
for myself but now I know I love
coaching and uh my coaches have all
asked me to create software to run their
companies the way that I run it I have
everything at Google Docs but it doesn't
scale and Google Docs is good so I said
okay I'll write this software but I
don't want to pay for it out of my own
pocket so you all have to pay your fair
share so now money gets charged and they
pay
um but the the surprising thing for me
is that how amazing
coaching is I think it's the best
freaking job that I've ever heard of
two reasons one I become really close
friends with the people I coach I mean
really deep connection
so
and that's something I value
tremendously I love having deep
connection with people I love having
close friends and now I get to have many
more and I actually get to choose the
people that I become close friends with
I mean it's it's amazing and then the
second thing is
I get to pretend that I'm actually
helping a company become better and the
analogy I'll give as I once went to a
friend's um hunting ranch in South Texas
and he had like 10 of us there and there
was like a pond and we all sort of sat
around stood around the Palm each had a
shotgun and birds would fly over and
we'd shoot at them and I would shoot and
I couldn't hit a thing and I was getting
frustrated so I finally saw the person
who was the most successful and I just
walked over and stood next to that
person and then a bird would come over
we'd both shoot bird would come down and
we weren't exactly sure who hit the bird
um and you know clearly it was the other
guy but I could pretend that maybe it
was me and so when I coach I can pretend
that maybe I'm in some small way
responsible for the success of this
organization and so that's a lot of fun
too and yet
I don't have to do any work
I don't do any actions like we sit there
in the meeting I show up for the
coaching meeting we talk about the
issues we talk about the next actions we
write them down I hold this CEO
accountable for doing these next actions
but I don't have any
so it's only the cream it's only the
funnest part of the job and not the
difficulty frankly which is actually
doing the work and so I can't think of a
better role I can't think of a better
position a more fun one
um maybe professional Surfer other than
that it's the best role I know
a lot of investors get vaulted into the
coach or advisor role whether they want
to or not and whether in the founders
realize that they are putting their
investors in that role or not as you
know many of those investors have no
experience being a coach in in the
classical sense uh they are kind of
winging it or they're giving their
personal opinions uh maybe without as
much thought as they should do you think
that all investors should go through
some sort of training or spend time
really understanding the different kind
of day-to-day actions of somebody like
you as a coach or is actually the
investor role maybe something a little
bit different actually the founder of
getting their personal opinions without
kind of a more structured coaching
approach is valuable and you want to be
able to give them that
well
I don't think there's actually too much
difference between what I do and what
investors do there's one key difference
and that is I make a CEO feel that I
truly understand the position that
they're in
before I give my advice
the most most people don't do that most
people just CEO says here's a situation
investor goes here's the answer
and then the reaction that the CEO has
which you probably won't say she won't
say is
that doesn't feel like it's customized
to my situation that feels just like
something that you did or you saw
somewhere else and you're like taking
that as a cookie cutter solution and
applying it to me therefore it doesn't
resonate therefore I don't know that I'm
actually going to do it and the only
difference between me and that investor
is that CEO tells me what their the
situation is and I go okay I think what
I'm hearing you say is that here's a
situation here's what's going on here's
how you're feeling
is that right
and the CEO goes yes that's it or the
CEO says no not quite and they change a
little bit and I say okay now what I
think I'm hearing you say is can I
repeat back what they said in the second
time is that right and they go yes
that's it I go great
here are my thoughts and I share them
and the founder goes wow that's awesome
I think I'm gonna do that
because the founder feels that my advice
is tailored to their situation because
they feel that I actually understand
their situation but if I just jump in
and give advice without first making the
founder feel heard and we'll put a link
to you know how to make someone feel
heard we've got a whole doc on it
if I do that then the CEO's reaction is
the same as it is to the investor like
ah that feels like a cookie cutter
solution uh it doesn't resonate with me
so every investor can become an
effective coach if all they do
is make the CEO feel heard
before the seat before the investor
gives advice that's it
it's incredible how simple it is
um when you think of the coaching
profession today is this something where
there's a limiting factor on how many
people you can actually talk with and
kind of keep up with and is that some
way solved with technology there's a lot
of maybe uh hype uh I'll also go even as
far as maybe promise of some of these AI
Technologies where people think that you
could be able to talk to it and it'll
give you advice and it can customize it
things like that how do you think about
humans versus technology and maybe the
limiting factor to a human-led coaching
business
and yeah I don't I haven't figured out a
way to scale it
um I can coach about
CEOs
and that means I'm only coaching CEOs
and I'm only talking to them
once or twice a month
and these are long in-depth formal
coaching sessions I you know can respond
to pings
um 24 7 365 with you know 10 15-minute
conversations when something comes up in
the moment but like the long we formally
go through did you do the actions from
before you know what are your next
actions towards your priorities what are
the issues you run into let's unpack
those what feedback you have for me
though that takes about two hours so we
do that about once a month
um and it's usually enough because then
we come up with a whole bunch of actions
that people need to actually have time
to go do
um before we want to sort of create a
whole another list of actions for people
for the CEO so I can do about I mean at
the max I can probably do 30 which I
have in the past but that feels like a
lot and
that's also me just coaching CEOs
it's not what Bill Campbell did what
Bill Campbell did was he would coach the
CEO and every member of the executive
team so he was coaching
12 people in each company and the value
of that is he could then pull out the
issues that the exec team members were
talking about were too afraid to bring
up in the exact team meeting so he would
bring them up and that's an incredibly
valuable function and I'm not doing that
I'm just talking to CEOs because
selfishly
I just enjoy coaching CEOs more so it's
a selfish choice on my part I'm not
saying it's more effective it's just
better for me
and the but there's I have not found a
way to scale that number so you can
either coach if you're coaching 12
people an exec team I think you'd
probably coach two companies at a time
or 25 to 30 individual CEOs at a time
I don't see how people can coach more
and you know chat EPT I mean there's
companies that have already made AI
versions of me and I've seen the results
and
they're not that good
they don't make people feel heard they
don't make people feel like they really
understand what the person is saying and
the situation they're in and that's key
and so
um I think we're a long way from being
able to AI coaching and at least the way
I do it and uh so yeah I love to find a
way to scale myself but I haven't found
it yet
what is the craziest situation that
you've been on the other
like side of the phone so I'm talking
two o'clock in the morning you get the
phone call there's Panic fear uh
uncertainty Etc don't use names if you
don't want to but just like
give people a sense for there's the hey
how are you we have a scheduled call uh
let's go through the priorities and then
there's the like the house is on fire
help what are those situations like or
what's an example of one
um two examples come to mind one is I
referred to it before when uh founder
we'd agree that he needed to let go an
executive but when the time came he
literally
couldn't sleep for days and nights
beforehand and was having full-blown
anxiety attacks and like was just in a
panic and and he called me and said I I
think I need to go to the hospital I
don't know what and I
I just I mean those are the moments I
love and I just talked him through what
is the worst thing that's going to
happen when you do this
and once he had to say that he realized
oh
actually that's not that bad
and then
I said okay now you're gonna now you're
then therefore gonna do this you're
gonna let the person go he says no I
still don't want to I said okay how
about I get on the phone with you he's
like well I don't know that's like weird
it's like okay who else will you have
there on the phone with you and you have
his coo so who was not in fear so she
was gonna do fine so we had him do it
with his coo as you talk about two
people on the call and she was able to
calm him down enough that he was able to
let the exec go
and as soon as he did I mean hours later
he called me and said Matt it's
incredible I feel so good now I feel
like a huge ton of weight has been
lifted off my shoulders I I I I I
couldn't have imagined that I would feel
this way so soon and this is amazing now
I realize that I was in total panic
before couldn't see that I was in panic
I thought that it was rational now I
realize it was completely irrational and
so that was probably the most extreme I
mean the guy literally thought he had to
go to the hospital and then
hours later was completely utterly fun
um the other ones that are really fun
for me are when people
either co-founders or CEO and board
member or CEO and exec team member
just
hate each other and CEO and exec team
member is pretty easy CEO just lets the
exactly never go but investor and CEO
kind of hard to separate co-founders
kind of hard to separate and so I do
this thing with them called conflict
resolution which I've again written up
and there's a doc there's a whole
process you can follow on your own
doesn't require me or anybody else and
it's just a matter of each person saying
around each emotion how they feel around
joy and around anger what are the
thoughts they have of the other person
and we go first through the joys so we
confirm that these people actually do
see value in each other and then we say
but I also feel anger and hear my
thoughts around that and we have the
other person make the first person feel
heard repeat it back and then decide if
they want to change that thing and
almost always they do
and so we have if we do this on both
sides and both people make the other
feel heard and then both people accept
the feedback and agree to change their
behavior
I've gone from my record was and I won't
name the company but it was a large
company it was over 10 billion dollar
market cap and
it was the only time I ever talked to
those two founders
theater called me up said does it you
know I don't know you Matt but would you
help I said sure and it was co-founders
and basically the company was about to
break apart they were about to just shut
the whole thing down because the two
hate each other and we met
on the back porch of one of the
co-founders the one who was saying I'm
out and that one that one like ran all
of engineering like if that guy left the
whole thing which again and uh and I
timed it it took 29 minutes
from the start of the conversation to
the two of them hugging each other
crying and saying I love you and that
company continues on today and exists
and is doing phenomenally well
what was that conversation like
it was exactly this like hey I I went
each one when you think about
when John you think about George and I'm
making these names up when you think
about George and you feel Joy what do
you think about he says oh well all the
great things we've done and all the
great things we're gonna do and it's
like great
and then
George when you think about John Phil
Joy what thoughts come to your mind well
it's you know it's he's so great at this
and he's so great at that and he started
this company together and there were so
many good moments and these the good
moments great so now they established
this positive link they see value in
each other
then I say okay now George when you
think about anger and you think about
this person what thoughts come to mind
they say Well it pisses me off that he
does great
John what'd you hear
what I heard is well
when I do
George gets pissed off and then I say
John is that right
and John says yes that's right great
George do You Wanna piss off John no
great
George
will you change these behaviors do you
accept this feedback we change it he
said yes I'm going to change these
behaviors great what will you do to
change these behaviors I'll do a b and c
great let's write that down as an action
okay
George if John does that well that
satisfy you
George says yes great
now let's do the reverse we do the
reverse
and the whole thing takes another 5-10
minutes now we're done now guys
you feel better about this you feel more
resolved and each one says yes I
absolutely do great now I'd like you to
either shake hands or hug or high five
whatever you have the most physical
contact you've had in the past I'd like
you to do it now and I do can I hug and
it's over
I've done this dozens of times and each
and every time the only time I actually
am willing to do it myself is when
people tell me this relationship is done
that's when I'll come in if they say ah
this relationship is challenging like
okay you can figure it out on your own
here are the steps to take do it on your
own but if they say the relationship is
done
then I get really excited that's when I
step in and facilitate it because I want
to see if I can pull it out of the fire
and so far
I think I've done it every time I don't
think I've I can't remember a situation
where it didn't work
so this is a great uh leading into my
question that I want to end on which is
do you enjoy finding the worst most
screwed up absolutely horrible
situations and that's kind of like your
world series or your Super Bowl is more
so the the companies that are messed up
the co-founder relationships uh the
inefficient organizations or
do you enjoy going into a business that
is pretty good but man if we unlock
these one or two things then it can be
absolutely amazing do you enjoy the the
average to above average or do you enjoy
the absolute horrible situations and you
got to go and clean it up
neither what I enjoy the most are the
best companies that are performing
incredibly well
and then when I go in and Coach them
there's always something
that's [__] up
and I go find it
and I say that's what I want to deal
with
and then we do and then we fix it and
then that company that was already doing
incredibly well then starts going like
this
and that's what I love the most
that's a great way to look at it is
basically the the thing they don't even
need they don't even know needs to be
unlocked if you're able to go ahead and
unlock that to a company that's already
doing very well then it's just you know
kind of unlimited future potential
that's right
and again that's what I get to pretend
like I actually had some input overall
over the success I I appreciate your
humility but uh your reputation precedes
you for many people who are listening or
watching this and you have been
absolutely fantastic to some of the top
CEOs in the world uh so I think that
you're doing just fine so please keep
doing what you're doing where can we
send people to find you on the internet
find out about coaching or find your
book
um the website is masharymethod.com
m-o-c-h-a-r-y Method we've got a group
of coaches that are just phenomenal that
are available to help CEOs become better
CEOs and build better companies
um we've got a my book is available on
Amazon but also online for free and then
we've got a whole curriculum that's also
available online for free I think if you
just do a Google search of moshari it'll
it'll come up
um yeah we believe in giving content
away for free
um we're not trying to monetize content
we want everyone to run great companies
and the more people that can the better
the only reason we have coaching is
because there are some people that want
to sort of very specific implementation
of what we're doing but one of the
funnest experiences I had is I um once
had investors say hey this is my best
performing portfolio company
from that would you be willing to coach
them so they do even better I said sure
So we connected and the CEO was happy to
talk to me he'd read my book three years
ago and loved it so he was happy to talk
to me and I said great should we do some
coaching together and he clearly knew
all my stuff and was using all my stuff
he's like Matt
um
I gotta tell you something I love your
stuff but I implemented it in the
company all of it three years ago and it
all worked and the company's doing
incredibly well and I don't really have
any problems now and so I don't think I
even need your coaching
and I said that's fantastic that's
actually the best answer I've ever heard
so our intent is to for people to do
this on their own but they're most
people aren't like that guy most people
want to be a little bit of hand-holding
while they're implementing these things
to make sure they get implemented the
right time first which is fine
um but if they're people that are
willing to experiment on their own
that's awesome too
I love it and kudos to that person for
uh for for being ahead of the curve Matt
thank you so much I really appreciate it
I learned a ton today I think the
audience will laugh as well and we'll
definitely do this again in the future
fantastic thanks so much